with you and Bella check to me it's got
to be somewhat annoying when there's
always this question Tom Brady greatest
of all time but if he didn't have Bella
check it wouldn't have achieved because
Bella check is the brains there in your
leg he does it through your head I think
it's a pretty shitty argument actually
that people would say that because again
I can't do his job and he can't do mine
right so the fact that you could say
would I be successful without him the
same level of success I don't believe I
would have been but Tom isn't there some
resemble in your part that he didn't
make you a patriot for life no because
this is a part for me in my life to
experience something very different and
there's ways for me to grow and evolve
in a different way that I haven't had
the opportunity to do that aren't right
or wrong that's just right for me I look
at it this way why not stop right now
and just say that's my legacy
what is this decision all about it I
never cared about legacy it's because it
was just time I don't know what to say
other than that like I I accomplished
everything I could in two decades with
an incredible organization incredible
group of people and that will never
change and no one can ever take that
away from me no one can undertake those
experience or Super Bowl championships
away from us there were there were
rumours two years ago that Belichick was
thinking about bringing in a new QB you
know once your decision though when you
heard that rumor did you say you know
[ __ ] this guy I am giving my life to
this team so many wrong assumptions were
made about our relationship or about how
he felt about me I know genuinely how he
feels about me I got into unchartered
territory where I was old I was an older
athlete and he started a plan for the
future which is what his responsibility
is and I don't fault him for that and
that's what he should be you and that's
what every coach should be doing not
that I would ever coach but you know if
I man ever in a position of authority I
would understand that too
you
you